I wasn't given any advice I wasn't even
aware of writers during most of my life
until I came to New York at the age of
21 after college what made me a writer
is what made me curious and what made me
curious was being of an American that
wasn't sure how American I was I think
this is true of a lot of foreign people
who have foreign parents and my mother
and father ran a store in the southern
part of New Jersey where I was born the
town is called Ocean City I was born in
1932 when I was 10 years old the war
World War 2 was very much being enacted
through the European theater and the
part of Italy that my parents come from
which the southern part was being
attacked by Allied forces Americans and
Canadians and British moving up through
the areas that were the centres of my
ancestry though I was born in New Jersey
as I said before I was 10 years old 11
years old 12 years old during that 1942
43-44 period and the only thing I
remember that made me a writer and the
curiosity that is necessary I think for
being the kind of writer I am a
nonfiction writer was it as a boy in the
store I would see my parents react
during the daytime in one manner as they
as they dealt with customers my mother
spoke English very well my father spoke
English with an accent and he worked in
the back of the store my mother worked
in the front of the store selling
dresses and what started me thinking
about other people was when I overheard
conversations between my mother and her
customers and I came very curious about
the women and their stories
my listening to the stories as women on
one end of the counter would talk across
the counter my mother in those legends
while browsing through the could the
clothing racks picking fabric of picking
dresses to try on they would be talking
about things and the things that they'd
be talking about weren't necessarily of
any significance in a social or
historical sense but they were revealing
a personal moods personal feelings and
during the war there was up references
to the war - to the rationing of food to
the to the lack of gasoline during
during that period and to the fear of
their their sons or maybe daughters in
the military service or their uncles our
fathers sir working in defense plants
late at night in faraway Philadelphia
which is 50 miles away and so as a Bowie
I was hearing references to the war
while being a remote from the war and at
the same time I was intimately involved
with the with the enemy of in the war
the Italians who of course were allied
with the Germans because my father's
three brothers were in the Italian Army
now you say what does have to do with
being a writer what this has to do with
a being a writer is this at a young age
I would eavesdrop in the store and hear
stories of American women talking about
their lives the kind of material that
might make for fiction writers the the
the the essence of fiction private life
at night I would hear in our apartment
above the store stores closed at seven
o'clock 6:30 I would hear my father who
wasn't very vocal during the day talking
very much about his fear of his
brother's welfare and the village itself
where his mother his widowed mother
lived and I was getting at this young
age a sense of story and how in this
little building with the store in the
first floor in the apartment on the
second floor the emergence of characters
in the changing personality between the
day and the night
the father was reticent during the day
no doubt interiorly
very defensive and possibly unsecure in
a sense of being pro-american
and at night more outspoken because
there weren't any customers that he had
to worry about being overheard what he
was saying I was just interested in a
story here now what was the story the
story is no story in a way but it's a
full full story of character inquiry
promoting my curiosity
patience the most important thing as you
perhaps in the beginning is definitely
curiosity the ability to be outside
yourself to see other people and wonder
wonder who are they how they different
from me how did they get through the day
and night what motivates them where did
they come from where did the parents
come from all this curiosity about
people next thing is to get to bridge
the the ignorance gap and get to talk to
these people I have that I that again
comes out of the store anybody in your
audience who is who had parents who had
a store kids who hang around stores
because their parents are the
proprietors or because the kids have a
job in a store learn at an early age to
deal with people of many different ages
as a kid I would see older people coming
into the store I would hear them talk I
would watch the way they moved what they
dressed how they looked how they'd
comported themselves so I'm dealing with
different age groups also in stores you
have to have good manners that's another
thing I picked up very quickly and it
helps in journalism I think good manners
store manners you always have to be
respectful toward the customer my
parents certainly that was a mandate in
their little business that I've
certainly followed what you need as well
as curiosity and being able to engage
people and be polite and presentable and
therefore make yourself acceptable to
strangers in the beginning you have to
have patience many journalists many
writers many curious people are curious
but not patient enough in in taking the
time properly the amount of time not
pushing it to patiently patiently a
court the people that they want that the
writer wants to know about that I in
this case would want to know about I'm
not I've never in a rush I take very
long time in my research and it does
never is is it interrupted with
note-taking and tape recording I never
do any of that what I do is try to
introduce myself
most most differentially to people I'm
curious about I tell them with sincerity
that I'm interested in them and why
and I am sincerely interested in these
people because they represent to me
something I believe is an enlargement of
my life these people are different from
me I am interested in describing the
difference I'm also interested in
bringing too for to the print to the
printed page their stories why because
I'm searching for material the material
I I search is reality real people but
most particularly people who are not
making the news people who are not
well-known
I've always wanted to be writing about
people that the reader perhaps heard
about for the first time because I wrote
about them
I was very different myself and I think
that a writer many writers whether
you're talking about the great fiction
writers Philip Roth or or the late judge
John Updike or the late william Styron I
mean they very much present something of
the the in the case of Roth particularly
the outsider and I was in the world of
nonfiction very much in the persona of
the outsider from that boy in the store
to the boy at Alabama and I'd write
little stories for the college newspaper
as I had written little stories I didn't
mention in the high skin the town weekly
mag New Jersey town weekly I would write
a school news I'd write about my fellow
students in grade school in high school
and later on when I was a college the
same and I was in writing fiction
I wanted to write nonfiction because I
thought that there wasn't much
difference between fiction and
nonfiction except in fiction you
imagined stories and you change the
names of living people that might have
inspired the stories and non fiction and
nonfiction which I wanted to do and did
do and do do I thought I want to write
stories but I don't want to change the
names that's the big difference between
what I do in a fiction writer does and
maybe a big difference between the
nonfiction that I advocate in advance
and personify from the nonfiction that
is strictly journalism it isn't
journalism what I'm doing it is stories
about real people and real names
I insist on real names I never make up
information what I do has been an
ordinate amount of time with the people
I write about but my ambition is to try
to describe realistically the life of
people particularly private people
ordinary people the sort of people who
went to my mother's dress shop when I
was a boy observing and eavesdropping I
was really motivated then as I still
have now at the age of 77 to write about
people that you might not have ever
heard of but perhaps through my efforts
as a writer my descriptive efforts by my
ambitions as a writer of scenes and
visual writing you will see them and you
will see them and you will understand
them and you will get a sense of the
people that it took Beale
long time to know but now I want to
communicate them to you and that's
really what I do